reports have been circulating that Mel
one of the best women's Valor players in
the world was denied trials for tier one
almost entirely male teams due to her
gender we have a lot to talk about so
take a seat and listen up
this week veteran reporter slasher
appeared on Sean Garrison's stream and
ended up speaking about Mel reportedly
being refused trials for teams due to
her gender from what I understand and
what I have heard Mel has not gotten
opportunities to even practice or scrim
with any Tier 1 teams because every
single time that she has approached with
her agent to try to make this happen
there has been at least one player on
the team that does not want to play with
a woman melting wasn't true with every
team it did happen with a couple teams
but not every team still sad it happened
at all I'm not gonna lie that shocks me
like that's actually
once these clips were shared it caught
like wildfire and made news everywhere
everyone in the industry was weighing in
slasher later clarified his comment
saying that it was not all because of
her gender rather in some scenarios that
Mel was unable to trial for teams it was
due to her buyout or other reasons that
had zero to do with sexism later the
night of September 19th Mel put out a
very lengthy statement she confirmed
that she had been at least once
considered for a tier one team but was
told a player was uncomfortable playing
with a woman she also stated that quote
I've been denied opportunities to trial
for co-ed valorant teams with a handful
of talented coed rosters over the years
for reasons that include teams not
wanting to pay a buyout for me and
because I was viewed as and I quote too
valuable of an asset to release this
close to partnership selection when I'm
so pivotal to my orgs application Mel
also described the mental toll that this
whole ordeal has taken on her and how
she just wants to focus on competing
with her team version one she was also
quick to give credit to the vast
majority of professional men in the
scene who have supported her saying I
don't believe that experience is in any
way indicative of the kind of
professional Community we have here yes
sexism is apparent in Esports I would
not be using my platform responsibly if
I attempted to deny any bad faith actors
or the stories of many other women who
have shared their negative experiences
in valorent and other Esports alright so
what do we do now I'm not going to lie
to you all I really struggled with this
video
as someone who's incredibly vocal about
women's opportunity in Esports and
gaming some of you might have noticed
that I was dead silent when this
happened and the reason I did that was
because it's not about me it's about Mel
even now I am really struggling with
this because I don't know the best way
to handle this I know Mel I have spoken
with part of the Mel I've gotten the
privilege now is incredibly kind and her
kindness is matched in tandem with her
wit she is hysterically funny some of
the quickest humor I've ever seen
unfortunately that gets lost in moments
like these what breaks my heart even
more is that Mel knows the kind of
damage that these comments can have she
said that this was shared publicly
without her consent and now all I can
focus on is how teams may think twice
about giving me a shot in the future
because of comments I never made but
will be forever associated with me
nonetheless she says to see her faces
and all the Articles was more defined
what you are seeing is a tried and true
Testament of how any young woman would
be treated in any industry the news and
gossip matters more than her opinions or
achievements she's a 9 I'm 50k Champion
the in-game leader of two of the best
teams the North American GC scene will
ever see but what will the public
remember her for that or comments she
never made is this the right thing to do
is is the right way to be handling this
am I the person to be handling this
I don't know and I don't feel
comfortable doing this story without
saying that to you all and I'm not going
to pretend like I am okay talking about
this am I being objective
hell no but I ask that you forgive me
for being unable to do so I'm poor you
when you do talk about this remember
that there's someone in the center of
this while this is a symptom of a much
bigger issue there is a young woman at
the heart of it all what you can also do
is support game changers show up to the
stream games learn about the players
learn about the teams the story lines be
a part of it Mal along with many other
people will be competing in gc3 and I
ask that you support them when they do
[Music]
thank you